Well, hello again, welcome to another read your genes podcast where we go over your questions on your genetics
So let's get started a couple of questions came in first one shouldn't I
Have been given more recommendations for supplements with all my genetic defects
Well, this is a common misnomer a lot of people think that because I have a genetic defect. There's a supplement that
Goes along with that. Well, you're not treating the defects
Make that perfectly clear. There's nothing you're doing that you're treating the defects. You can't treat the defects
That's not what you're doing
When you have a lot of defects in a gene family, maybe it's wise if there's no
Nutritional things that will support that are dietary things that will support that pathway
That you maybe take a nutritional supplement or that you choose to take do dietary or lifestyle changes dietary
Life-style changes are always the best
so
Certainly you're not gonna treat each defect. That's not the whole point of doing a genetic test
It's to look at families of genes where you might have a lot of defects that could cause
Possibly caused doesn't mean that they are let's say I have double the old defects on everything in the family
It doesn't mean you're still that that gene is not still working. It just means you have a greater chance of it
Maybe not working the way it was supposed to so
It's you know those are the ones that I choose. I'm just making a clinical judgment on what I think
Would be best for you. We certainly not gonna take you know 50 supplements based on my genes
I think that's gonna solve my problems
It's not we don't want to just throw more supplements at the game. We want to look at lifestyle
and
daily
Life changes that are gonna that are gonna support those pathways
How do we get defects in our genes? That's a common question, too
Well, you get G defects are genes because you inherit them from your parents
But sometimes genetic defects or
Changes in our genes are complimentary to our environment over time
If they improve our ability to deal with an adapt to our environment
So some defects are positive some defects are because of
toxins in our environment that that
That damage those genes so we can have defects in our genes because we inherited from our parents and we can have defects in our genes because
Toxic exposure damaging our genes and then we will pass
Even more defects on to our offspring if we have children after that time
So that's how they happen
We don't go away
Can I get testing for my children if so at one age?
Yes, you can there are now cheek swab tests where you could just do
Just do a cheek swab instead of having to spit into a thing in the past it was like well
Child has to be at least all enough to be able to spit into that tube
Now you can do the cheek swab genetic test
So basically you could do it at any age
Is there benefit to doing it at a younger age? Well, yes, I know it does give you clues on lifestyle
But if you've done genetics on yourself, you can get a pretty good idea. What's going on with your child?
Let's say if you have a double allele defect your child is going to have definitely at least a single allele defect
If you have a double allele defect and and you're the mother and the father as a single allele defect or
a double allele defect
Child is definitely going to have a double allele defect
So it's you can get a clue on your children's genetics by looking at your genetics
But if you really want to see what's going on with your child if your child is having problems
Definitely if you need to support their detox pathways and such that can really help you
Make clinical decisions for your child. So
Yeah, you can do your child's genes at any time. That's sure if
D-Day supplementation has recommendations on
At what age you could start, but I don't think there's you know any hindrance of doing children at young ages now with the cheek swab test
Okay, remember to send your questions in on the course in that little blue box on the course if you can submit your questions and
We'll see you next time